und zum tagesgespräch war phoenix
begrüße ich ganz herzlich professor
frank brettschneider
kommunikationswissenschaftler
guten morgen
guten morgen grüße sie als
kommunikationswissenschaftler was würden
sie sagen der wahlkampf gewinner oder
kommunikations gewinner ist wer
die spd das hätte ja niemand zugetraut
anfang des jahres aus diesem bereich in
dem sie sich da bewegt hat etwa 15 so
raus zu kommen das liegt jetzt nicht
alles an der spd sondern da haben cdu
und grüne auch richtig viele fehler
gemacht aber die spd hat diese fehler
genutzt zu ihren gunsten und steht jetzt
so da wie das keiner für möglich
gehalten hätte wäre das dann auch
gleichzeitig das überraschendste moment
des wahlkampfes für sie
ja wäre es verbunden mit den tatsächlich
vielen fehlern die cdu und grüne gemacht
haben sowas habe ich noch nicht erlebt
in den wahlkampf dass gleich zwei sehr
aussichtsreiche parteien die eigentlich
ihre koalition schwarz-grün unter dach
und fach hatten im märz dann in der
heißen phase wenn es darauf ankommt ob
um pleiten pech und pannen
aneinanderreihen das war in strecken
auch ziemlich unprofessionell
pleiten pech und pannen sind ja nicht
automatisch inhalte inhalte sind doch
eigentlich gefragt oder
ja aber die inhalte müssen vermittelt
werden und dazu gehören personen die
spitzenkandidaten verleihen dem programm
ihrer partei gesicht und stimme und das
müssen sie dann auch gut machen man muss
verstehen verständlich nachvollziehen
können worum geht es eigentlich was sind
die hauptunterschiede und da hat man bei
armin laschet nicht wirklich viel zu
beginn erkennen können warte so fast den
eindruck er will sich ins
bundeskanzleramt merkel also mit einer
mit einem wahlkampf reinkommen der
eigentlichen amtsinhaber wahlkampf ist
und er funktionieren kann wenn man eine
leistungsbilanz wahlkampf führt das kann
er nun nicht und diese thematische erben
die ist eben dann auch tatsächlich auf
die füße gefallen also ist dann
effektive diese raute um ins kanzleramt
zu kommen
die raute ist nun auch für die meisten
menschen eine nebensächlichkeit wenn sie
das überhaupt mitbekommen haben aber sie
ist ein schönes symbol wie olaf scholz
tatsächlich versucht hat er den
merkel-wahlkampf
anzunehmen und zu imitieren und zwar
über diese art und weise auch eine
wichtige botschaft zu transportieren
mit mir gibt es beides einerseits
stabilität sie kennen mich schon so wie
frau merkel dass auch immer betont hat
und auf der anderen seite will ich aber
etwas anders machen als nabucco es gibt
auch den wandel und in der bevölkerung
ist ja so ein bedürfnis da beides zu
haben einerseits stabilität in
krisenzeiten und auf der anderen seite
aber eine veränderung in der politik nur
nicht zu stark erhitzt diese begriffe
die sich in so einem wahlkampf
herausbilden ich hab mal vier ausgesucht
die gehen wir mal nacheinander
durchgeschleust
geschafft
sich auf eine art und weise in der
diskussion verhalten das vorwürfe an
einem abtropfen so teflon artig ein
kleines bisschen lakonisch unaufgeregt
früher hat man gesagt langweilig und
dynamisch und zwischen sagt man da hat
sich einer hingeschaut also lässig
locker unaufgeregt sich nicht aus der
ruhe bringen lassen ok ihre einschätzung
nächster begriff verbirgt
ja verbirgt ist wenn man eine gute
startposition hat alle trümpfe in der
hand und sie dann eins nach dem anderen
aus der hand gibt angefangen bei den am
nach meldungen von zahlungen dann über
den lebenslauf und die plagiate im buch
verbockt verbockt man wird sagen können
dass die grünen nicht so gut abschneiden
wie sie hätten abschneiden können liegt
zu einem großen teil an ihr nächster
begriff und genau zuhören bitte lassen
ja das ist eine aufforderung von vielen
unions-anhängern an ihren
spitzenkandidaten und bevor ihr
spitzenkandidat wurde
armin laschet hätte es sein lassen
sollen mit der spitzenkandidatur
persönlich hätte die deutlich größeren
chancen gehabt wenn man es nur aus der
perspektive
der attraktivität bei den wählerinnen
und wählern betrachtet da wäre sicher
der bessere kandidat gewesen die
aufforderungen an armin laschet ist auch
sein zu lassen ist da vor diesem
hintergrund nachvollziehbar okay lass
ich auch unkommentiert weil ich da ja
nur die frage nämlich die nächste der
begriff unverblümt
unverblümt da müssen sie mir auf die
sprünge helfen ich denke mal
einrichtungen csu und bayern und kleine
pikante spitzen die immer wieder mal von
dort gesendet werden in richtung armin
laschet weil der stachel tief gesteckt
und der schmerz groß ist dann darüber
dass die cdu
insgesamt nicht wird gut abschneiden
können und die csu in bayern ja auch
nicht über ihre direktmandate dennoch in
den bundestag einziehen aber von dem
selbst gesteckten ziel wahrscheinlich
ein ganzes stück entfernt bleiben ja
gemeint war natürlich der
generalsekretär der csu markus blume in
diesem fall der ja immer wieder rein
sticht okay die begriffe lassen wir mal
sein körper mal zum besten redner
wahlkampf redner da wurde ich weiß gar
nicht mehr von wem christian lindner
gekürt auch ihre wahl
ja wenn man jetzt nicht auf die inhalte
achte zu sagen das hat ja auch der
redenschreiber verband nicht getan
sondern auch das rhetorische geschickt
die art und weise wie eigene positionen
dargestellt werden auch mit beispielen
versehen werden präsentiert werden und
auf eine für die eigene wählerschaft
gute art und weise transportiert werden
dann ist christian lindner tatsächlich
würde ich auch sagen an der spitze der
rednerinnen und redner und wie würden
sie den wahlkampf einschätzen wir im
internet und in den sozialen medien
geführt wurde gab es da die erwartete
schlammschlacht vor dfb vor der viele
gewarnt haben
ja diese erwartete schlammschlacht hat
es gegeben das was in sozialen
netzwerken oder messenger diensten zu
beobachten ist ist wirklich sehr
betrüblich und besorgniserregend da
kennen dann hass und hetze auch kaum
noch grenzen auf der anderen seite muss
man sich fragen wie relevant ist das für
die wählerschaft insgesamt die meisten
menschen neben den wahlkampf dann eben
doch nicht über soziale netzwerke war
sondern über gute alte analoge medien
angefangen bei dem klassischen
wahlplakat über broschüren aber auch mal
werbespots im radio oder im fernsehen
oder anzeigen in der zeitung dass die
sozialen netzwerke nicht verharmlosen
aber man muss ein bisschen in relation
sehen war dass der kampf gegen hass und
hetze im netz eine daueraufgabe ist für
uns als gesellschaft das ist glaube ich
auch in dem wahlkampf wieder klar
geworden diesem punkt wollen wir auch
noch setzen ich hatte eine ganz viele
fragen vielleicht noch eine zum schluss
weil wir auf den letzten metern kurz vor
der bundestagswahl sind wie erreicht man
die last minute vela und die taktischen
wähler jetzt noch
mal nur direkte ansprache und eine
zuspitzung warum geht das ist die
zweitstimme eine kanzler stimme dann
läuft das zugunsten von olaf scholz oder
ist die zweitstimme eine richtung stimme
bei der entschieden wird über eine
zusammensetzung von koalition dann hat
auch die cdu csu noch eine chance
entschieden ist da noch gar nichts kommt
auf die letzten meter tatsächlich
diesmal an ich denke ganz herzlich für
ihre einschätzungen danke fürs gespräch
professor frank brettschneider
danke ihnen